[تصفيق]
اختراع النجمه الكره الاسطوريه الراحه
البوليه مقبره خارجه عن المالوف ليدفنا
فيها وتحديدا في الطابق التاسع من مبنى فخ
من يطل على ملعب سانتوس حيث تالق وحظيا
بالنجاحات في عالم كره القدم
وستقام اليوم مراسم جنازه المفتوحه
للجمهور المزيد من التفاصيل مع زميل نسيم
بن معمر
في مدينه سانتوس جنوب البرازيل من المرتقب
بان يتجمع عشره الاف لالقاء النظره
الاخيره على اسطوره البرازيل الكرويه
الراحل البولي في جنازه تاريخيه سي يوضع
فيها نعشه وسط الملعب الذي لعب فيه اطول
فتره في مسيرته الكرويه على ان يتم دفنه
يوم الثلاثاء الثالث من يناير
على شاطئ مدينه سانتوس يكرم عشاق اللاعب
الراحل بولي ذاكرته خلال الاحتفال بميلاد
العام الجديد
10,000 البرازيليين مهووسون بكره القدم
وبالملاحم الكبيره التي صنعها الراحل في
النادي المحلي للمدينه وفي المنتخب الوطني
اشكره ببساطه لكل ما قدمه انا ممتن باسم
البرازيل باسم مدينه سانتوس والشعب
البرازيلي
في وداع بولي يختلط الحداد والحزن بمشاعر
الفخر ببطل رياضي سجل اكثر من 1300 هدف في
مسيرته وفاز بكاس العالم
ثلاث مرات
[تصفيق]